des rires pour conjurer les drames vécus
derrière la joie des retrouvailles se
cache un grand débit et beaucoup
d'impatience
du canada m'a assuré que j'étais
admissible au programme de réfugiés
parce que j'avais travaillé pour eux
d'aller saada karimi et afghanes
et la fuye kaboul il ya huit mois et
depuis elle attend une réponse du canada
sa demande de réfugié
cette cinéaste de renommée
internationale est la première femme à
diriger l'institut du film afghans
elles profitent de l'hospitalité de son
ami aux états unis avant de retourner en
europe
[Musique]
je suis une femme afghane avec tout ce
que les femmes peuvent endurer dans une
société patriarcale
antoine comté et qui ne respectent pas
les femmes autonomes
mais
nous sommes désolé d'apprendre que vous
traversez une situation difficile son
découragement est visible plus notables
rené note que votre demande est toujours
en cours comme des dizaines de milliers
d'afghans elle se heurte à la lenteur
des processus d'immigration et neuf
matches mais le temps est un luxe
qu'elle ne peut souffrir a dit m j'ai
travaillé pour eux mais ils m'ont écrit
qu'ils avaient des préoccupations quant
à mon admissibilité prenez votre temps
alors mes nièces n'ont pas été à l'école
depuis presqu'un
son frère et ses nièces attendait leur
visa canadien en ukraine la guerre les a
rattrapés fait une trâlée jda
l'encourageant votre famille à prendre
toutes les mesures légales qu'elles
jugent nécessaires d
en dehors de cette demande malgré ces
épreuves pas question pour elle de dire
que le canada ont fait plus pour les
ukrainiens que pour les afghans les df
les ukrainiens mérite toute l'aide qu'on
leur offre mais les afghans aussi boîte
- président le coach et mon président a
fui le pays par contre le jeune
président ukrainien lui est toujours là
bas et chaque jour ils prouvent au monde
entier qu'il défend son pays everyday
divine
à 36 ans il fait partie de cette
jeunesse afghane qui a connu la présence
américaine dont elle garde un
arrière-goût amer
aof la
france le succès de ces vingt dernières
années aura été l'avènement d'une
nouvelle génération d'afghans des
milliers de femmes ont fréquenté les
écoles et les universités nous
participions activement à la société
mais la communauté internationale et les
états unis ne nous ont pas fait
confiance ils ont plus des seigneurs de
guerre et des politiciens corrompus pour
le thé chez eux pendant que la coalition
internationale chercher à maintenir le
fragile équilibre politique en
afghanistan
sarah karimi essayé à travers le cinéma
de sauvegarder un outil essentiel à la
survie du pays la culture a dit j'ai
décidé de mettre en place des plans
quinquennaux pour encourager les jeunes
cinéastes indépendants à faire des films
en sort j'ai aussi milité pour une
représentation internationale du cinéma
afghans
elle a pu compter sur le soutien de son
ancien patron l'ex ministre afghan de la
culture lui même en exil à washington si
jobs
adresse english us
speaking out of the box de l'ardeur au
travail est une franchise qui ont
bousculé les codes iphone rue
mais
elle a travaillé sur un documentaire
pour les nations unies financé par le
canada et d'oise mais doivent-ils
s'agissait d'un documentaire sur la
promotion de la santé de la femme
mais ses liens avec le canada sont bien
plus profonds sa mère et sa soeur y
vivent
j'ai beaucoup de liens avec le canada
d'ailleurs je collabore un film canadien
on a besoin de femmes comme sarah
qui peuvent nourrir notre
cinématographie pour sortir un peu des
murs du québec et du canada
oui spock leur béret basque ray les deux
artistes collaborent depuis quelques
mois sur le long métrage canadien kaboul
montréal une très grande valeur ajoutée
c'est une femme qui a un doctorat
une femme qui éduque et c'est une femme
qui peut apporter beaucoup à la société
d'ici avec son propre métier lorsqu'on
lui parle du statut de la cinéaste
afghane elle ressent la même
incompréhension c'est plus que lent
c'est une descente aux enfers pour
toutes ces femmes ces hommes là qui sont
éparpillés à travers la planète qui ont
qui n'ont pas de job qui ont pas
d'argent
qui attendent des papiers pour pouvoir
venir au canada
sarlat airs de maison en maison de ville
en ville 18 capital et autant de
festivals de cinéma d'université ou
d'amis qui l'ont accueilli à left every
thing j'ai tout laissé en afghanistan in
white - dans la nef j'ai fermé la porte
je suis parti alors
j'ai perdu mon contact avec les miens
j'ai perdu mon inspiration mais malgré
cela je veux continuer à y croire
cette cinéaste a besoin d'une nouvelle
terre d'accueil peut-être au canada pour
retrouver son inspiration
[Musique]